[Music]
all right welcome to mastering the
middlegame
as usual I've dumbed down the lecture
since I'm a grandmaster so I'll make it
so low low-key that even okay you can do
it yeah he can do it over there we
actually have a master in the audience
okay so since the old guys are playing
well lately not me but like Yvan Chuck
as far as we know Ivanka looks great but
this is two weeks later so you guys are
like Yvan trick lost all his games on
day three what do you mean but as far as
we know Yvan tricks great
so Avant ryx playing in the world rapid
which has many many many many strong
grandmasters and he's in first place and
he'd beat Magnus Carlsen today very
convincingly and he has eight out of ten
which is reasonable since the average
ring of his opponents is about 2,700 so
a good performance rating and another
player who's doing well lately is Vishy
Anand another player who's pretty good
is Vladimir Kramnik so since the 40 year
old guys are killing it I was thinking
let's look at middle games from an older
player when they were younger confusing
the audience which is usually my goal
right Arjun okay and so who who better
to look at openings and middle games and
mastering the middle game than none
other than Garry Kasparov okay and I
don't want to be the use to police but
he used to be good okay so now these
games were actually played a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away and this
game was played in 83 when Kasparov was
how old I'm sure you all know when he
was born Arjun is doing the math so that
means you don't know when he was born
because there's no math you know 63 to
83 is 20 years you'll have to do math
okay so Kasparov was 20 when this game
was played and the next game was played
when he was 17
and he was pretty good at the the middle
game when he was younger than when he
got older every game was a draw geary
style okay that was before geary okay
fact Kasparov played in one of the
Linares tournaments
was very strong out of 14 games he drew
13 that was near the end of his career
at the beginning of his career he
usually had 13 decisive games now one of
my good friends is a V Friedman and
people like his lectures and he comes
here often to do the big tournaments he
helps out for the live commentary he's
the guy in their ear telling him this
guy won that guy resigned go to this
game insider etc and he does the puzzles
also and this is one of Abby's favorite
games he's memorized it but that would
take second so I'm not going to do that
i memorize games from 150 years ago so
when I'm 130 years old all of you guys
this game memorized it takes me a while
and this is the game which I'm sure you
all know cuz smart off poor dish and
Leos poor dish let me tell you how
strong he is
I lost to his brother 20 years ago I
think it's 30 years ago and everybody
knows his brother's name good timing
now you're famous okay so you know it's
funny currently not for you at home
currently there are some st. Louis
players in Las Vegas playing in the
North American open the North American
Open is much weaker than usual because
all the good players of the US are to
Pan Am's because all the u.s. players
are there good our college students wink
which I say wink anyway so there's like
40 grandmasters playing in the college
tournament instead of those 40
grandmasters playing in Vegas um so
Vegas isn't very strong there for
Grandmaster Ken West when he figured
he's a grandmaster than the grandma and
he actually drew a higher way to play in
the first round okay what if he was
dreaming anyway the point of the story
if there is one is Ken West was walking
around there like Ken West and he's like
yeah says are you the ken west the he's
like I'm a Ken West
he was the kennel West so this actually
happened to come er about a year ago
like are you might cover from the Chess
Club videos he's like yeah and now it's
with Ken West so he's the most famous
kind of West clear is or will ever be
anyway a V Friedman who I was talking
about earlier and we went off on a
tangent this is one of his favorite
games
because because Bob just rolls over his
opponent is opponent do anything wrong
so that just proves that white wins in
chess Bobby chess is a draw but I want
your plinkus tomorrow okay so Kasparov
is white and they played a Queen's
Indian and if you know Kasparov you know
what move he played here because he
basically stole the Petrosian variation
what's that and the master knows amazing
high 93 he tricked you good job actually
because smart I've always played a three
and then he lost a famous game to Viktor
Korchnoi in a candidates match 1 to 1984
then he won all the other games so ok so
Knight c3 Kasparov likes to play a3 and
stop the pin and he did here so Porteous
could have played Bishop to b4 but he
decided to play this should be 7 a3 and
we transpose to the Kasparov variation
what's funny about this is most games
they're not playing a3 anymore however
there was one played today this position
occurred the world rapid with two of the
best players in the world what was the
result
I don't remember how to teach in camp
all day so I spent rest the day after
camp crying and during the camp so right
Arjen the artisans like yeah I know that
camp ok so a three Knights III was the
Petrosian variation because far off
stole it and Petrosian was known to play
somewhat boring chess Kasparov not so
when Petrosian played it it was to stop
Bishop before it loses a tempo it gives
white a very tiny advantage when
Kasparov played it he checkmated you so
the truth hurts
okay d5 cd5 95 this is all normal pawn
to e3 some of you would want to play e4
unfortunately after Knight takes Knight
you're a pawn is not sufficiently
defended a brilliant pawn sacrifice by
accident okay so e3 Knight c3 which is
unusual this should be 7 this should be
5 check because he wants black to play
c6 because then the bishop is sort of
silly he also wants black to play Knight
then because 95 is good so attribution
should be 5 check it's hard to play a
normal move if you play Bishop c6 the
bishop moves away and now you can't play
C 5 so this should be 5 check it's sort
of a nuance that we see in a lot of
openings and of course portage played c6
because it'll just play c5 anyway then
c5 ok getting one move closer to the
time control yeah that's true if white
apply Bishop d3 and black plays c5 did
it get into time trouble ok Karpov would
approve knight c6 and now Bishop b2 and
actually this reminds me of a game I
don't have to tell you what to tell them
of the game Bobby Fischer Ronald
Feingold
which I recently showed in a lecture
because Fischer and a French defense
also put his Bishop behind all these
pawns confusing the spectators hopefully
you're confused
it shows how strong you are again and
some of you are like evil dis Bishop bow
that sounds good it is good because
eventually these puns will move and the
dishes will be very strong on the
diagonal and the bishop can't move right
now to somewhere like f4 g5 so we got to
move it somewhere and even though the
bishops not great right now it has
potential and it helps white connect the
rooks and put them in the center Rick c8
Queen e2 castles
Rick a d1 now when I give Morphy
lectures which I do often I talk about
how more if he moved every piece ok he
didn't just move one piece and then say
wow that was interesting
ah and Kasparov of course wrote the
famous series of books you there we go
my great predecessors he talks about all
the great players before him obviously
he studied the world champions and the
great players of the past and like every
other strong player today when he plays
the middle game although he doesn't play
now because now I would show him who the
boss is him ok they didn't hear that did
that so Kasparov like I do when I play
when I went occasionally
moves a different piece every move
getting all of his pieces active of
course poor Tish isn't a bad player he
gets all his pieces out also
unfortunately black doesn't have a lot
of pieces near his King and there was a
game played today not for you but for
you which I was just looking at with
Danny Machuca it was a game Carlson
played against Yaakov anko and the end
of that game was very interesting it was
two queens against the queen and six
pawns I've never seen that before
but in the middle game Carlson tried to
attack by plague efore e5 Yaakov anko
had nothing near his King so Yaakov onco
traded all the pieces off and he got to
a drawn ending and then he lost it
hmm Carlson winning a drawn ending never
heard of that oh wait a minute that's
every game okay so here because probably
is a twin drawn ending is consuela of
checkmates you that's how he rolls okay
that's more exciting for the spectators
okay
although the match Carlson cargo is
pretty interesting
long pause not so Queen c7 and I like
that move because when my opponents rook
is opposite my queen I don't want to see
the move rook takes Queen
so Queen c7 I like okay c4 which is
right and it gets out of the way the
bishop so now we're ready to go
unfortunately for black white has two
bishops on the diagonals getting towards
black King and black doesn't have a
knight on f6 that would be a nice night
to have then the bishop on b7 would not
be hindered and the night would be
defending the king but that's the way
life goes C takes D for each takes d4
and these pawns are known as hanging
pawns okay
and when we say hanging pawns when we go
into the Chess Club and watch them play
blitz chess those are different hanging
pawns those are pawns they're just
hanging right Arjun we have a lot of
brilliant sacrificial masters playing
whoops just over there if only they knew
they were sacrificing so hanging pawns
are neither good nor bad they're both
they're good when you win and your pawns
control the squares and they're bad when
your opponent takes them okay so in this
game white one so they're good but if
black had won you would have said Wow
look at those weak pawns what have that
what a pot sir and black has a very nice
pawn structure you can't no doubled
pawns no isolated pawns these are the
hanging pawns
this one's isolated Black has everything
developed sounds good 95 attacking the C
pawn not only does it attack the C pawn
it opens up the diagonal for the bishop
okay and this is the difference between
strategy and tactics and strategy I
don't think as part of what's superior
to other strong grandmasters but an
ability to calculate and figure out
material deficits and figure out
attacking chances he was slightly better
than the gentleman who just walked in if
I said his name the whole video would be
banned okay so we just say the person
just walked in okay initial is our DM
okay I think it's like draw master so it
was Geary now okay so the problem is
blacks position looks nice but his King
doesn't have a lot of protection and
whites Knight can come in White's Bishop
can go here the other bishop is coming
the queen is coming winter is coming you
didn't get that joke you can't you can't
laugh winter is coming as a book
Kasparov Road but it's not a chess book
so nobody read it BAM
man I might get B in for that no no I
can make fun of cats profits okay all
right
now we'll get back to making fun of
Nakamura all right raise your hand if
you know how many points Nakamura has
right now
out of ten you oh good answer
extra credit it's really one but I like
it
okay now he's playing in an open turn
where he just play everybody so he
should have like eight out of ten like
Yvonne Chuck but he has five and a half
out of ten because the truth hurts right
chess is hard okay so remember I was
telling you the bishop on beats who's
going to get good and you were taking
notes Ben's a liar Ben's a liar Ben's a
liar it's true but not about this so if
we want our Bishop b2 to be really
really good
and we're a 20 year old Kasparov what
move do we play what's that have you
memorized this game he's like no but
your hints are really good okay
somehow the highest rated player knows
all the answers d5 okay and we might
lose a pawn but cuz prob didn't care
about pawns he cared about checkmate and
peace activity now that Bishop on beats
who is looking pretty good then we must
take takes takes Kasparov immediately
wins his pawn back with the obvious
Misha page 7 and rook d5 but you would
think how do you check mate somebody if
you're trading all the pieces off good
question Danny Machuca is like yeah
what's going on here you can't do any of
that okay and the reason is all of
Wight's pieces are pretty close to the
black King Black has a lot of pieces
that are not close to his King
especially the knight on a 5 and well
Generali would be happy because we're
going to have a Rover soon ok there Rick
went to d5 it's going to go to h5 or g5
ok King g8 trying to get back and again
lowered Kasparov play in this position
the scariest move ever Arjun Rick h5
even scarier Bishop g7 didn't see that
coming ok and Bishop g7 was not
unnecessary but Kasparov was 20 so when
he was 20 he saw more than the typical
super computer so he analyzed many many
many variations he was like that's good
that's good that's good that's good so
you play Bishop g7 of course he could
have played rook h5 or just attacked
slowly it had a really good position but
that's not how Kasparov played ok black
has to take or just be a pawn down and
getting mated and 95 so now white wants
to play queen g4 check white wants to
play rook to d7 and even though there's
no immediate win or threats black
doesn't really have a good defense here
because most of his pieces are on the
Queen side and this is called a
long-term sacrifice there's no pawns
that are going to
Roback here for black it's not bug house
where black can play g6 h6 f6 and be
safe so even if he doesn't meet him
right away
he knows in the long run I have more
pieces attacking than black has
defending and if you are playing a super
computer it might defend perfectly but a
human with the clock ticking and this
was 1983 so the clock was ticking the
clock don't take anymore right Arjun
yeah Arjun is like let's say I know odd
[ __ ] right you agree do you donate in a
wok clock is you do what is it getting
that crazy you ever play with those why
I use somebody else's clock and they
were like 90 years old okay so yeah this
was an 83 so we didn't use digital
clocks too much they existed but we
didn't use them okay so Rick FDA and
this does two things black wants to
trade rooks because when somebody is
meeting you it would be good to trade
rooks that they might not meet you what
else does it do that helps black a
little bit anyone you you raised your
hand yeah no the truth hurts sorry which
is the escapes square right so now the
King instead of being stuck on the
ancient G file getting mated by the
Queen and the rook we can play King f8
also I pointed out rook d7 might be
annoying but it's not annoying now okay
so that's what happened
you check then you got to the escape
square unfortunately when you have a
rook on f1 which white does or a rook on
f8 which black did you're defending your
F pawn and when you move it away you're
not as in the game Chris ankov Nakamura
everybody's not know they're not nodding
I'm kidding
now anybody nothing no sorry my here
okay so this game I lectured about
before you were born
well before Arjun was born and this is a
game where Nakamura was black and played
Queen takes F to check upon and
krasnikov was king walk all up the board
you don't know this game you you'll like
that game
yeah krasnikov Nakamura that's his
favorite game that'll always be his
favorite game he's hacked the Queen for
a pawn then the King walked up the board
as in the game of Rabat Kotov from
Zurich oh you're so close
53 yeah okay and we Reese act as Queen
and the King walks up the board very
similar okay so because we're I'll play
Queen f5 with obvious threats they see
it they pretend they don't but they do
yeah right four-move checkmate Queen f7
okay so we have to stop Queen f7 and he
played f6
what's wrong with f6 you ya never play
of six luckily I was only 13 years old
at the time so he could break my rule
okay so maybe it's hard to play black
here good play Bishop to d6 very
suspicious I wouldn't play f6 I'd be
afraid to play f6 because it weakens all
the white squares I like my plot on f7
so I would play Bishop d6 and lose
differently in a 90 a3 that was
Microsoft's motto lose differently okay
too complicated for this class all right
f6 boo 97 check mmm this looks pretty
tough for black okay and he sacrificed
an exchange because black still has a
small material advantage but by trading
all the pieces there's no way he'll get
mated also I don't really see a good
move here for black
I see moves they get checkmated but I
don't see good moves so I like rip takes
d7 and Queens c5 and Kasparov traded
Queens and won the endgame see they're
actually laughing that's good
okay now you play Queen age 7 the truth
hurts okay and it's extra difficult when
you're playing somebody with a big
reputation Carlsen kramnik and you think
wow that guy's pretty good then they're
playing you they're sacking material
everything you see is made
your flag is hanging you figure they're
playing well and you're really scared
so because spar when he was 20 was
pretty scary less scary now but scary
when he was 20 because he calculated
really well and he always attacked and
most of his attacks were sound so that
was a tough combination rook c7 trying
to trade more and now there's more than
one way to checkmate his opponent Queen
check Rick d3 and I like this rigged e3
idea because instead of attacking on the
seventh rank which is impossible because
blacks Rick is on the seventh rank he
tries to play Rick g3 and attack over
there
if white could move twice rep g3 Queen
g8 May and other moves we win also and
rook h3 wreck age 7 isn't bad either
so he's sort of evicted the rook
but it's being evicted to a better
square why is the attack working well
this nights over here if we put the date
on g7 or a 5 or G 5 or 6 or FAA that
maybe black would be ok but as soon as
black played Knight a5 that's the moment
because smart off play d5 he doesn't
sacrifice every game but when he
sacrifices he has a good reason and in
the middle game instead of saying whoa
instead of playing in certain people's
style of I'm going to sacrifice every
game you could say all my opponent put
all his pieces over there
now all sacrifice also he sacrificed
every game because he was 20 okay Knight
c4 hey you did what I said he got his
night back in the game rook FD one more
fee style getting all the pieces into
the attack 95 Queen Czech Queen check
and blacks kick is nice and safe
now and g4 check and when you play a g4
check it's because you see all the way
to the end not like oh now my king has
expired I shouldn't have done that
Sunkist Amaro plays g4 he knows the rest
of the game already he moves up Ric t4
King moves up and now as in the game
short Tim on white resigned no nothing
now you don't get that you don't get
that oh you get it okay yeah what was
the winning the last move in short Tim
on what was he going to do what King H
see there you go
right so in short watches King up it was
intentional not because Kasparov was
maiding him and believe me
Kasparov made it short plenty okay
especially last year here at the Chess
Club BAM
short got one and a half out of ten and
he was lucky to even get that many
points Queen b3 check so my two favorite
moves of this game are retreats
I like retreating when Kasparov moved
his rook back from d7 and then we've
just queen back to b3
so King e2 isn't very good because of
Queen e3 mate and there's probably other
mates I don't see like Rickey for is
almost mate
close enough right it's not made but
it's close and there's probably other
mates like rooks for to d2 that's
probably it so here he resigned if he
plays the obvious move Queen c3 then
white plays the obvious move yes where
rook d3 didn't say which one because it
didn't matter
very good right right that's what
doesn't matter right yeah and also a
funny variation for you at home
if black tries to steal a pawn in this
position or doesn't place King f4 or
King g4 Queen g3 check wins the rook the
truth hurts
you're losing anyway but now you lose
quicker okay so let's say you take and
then check when Zurich ah too bad so
somehow with blacks King on f3 he lost
no that actually makes sense
yeah but blacks did get his life back
into play so that's good
well I'll play top six yeah
well King f3 and f4 you're different
that's a big difference okay so that
made a lot of sense for you at home but
mainly for the people here alright so
that was conspire I when he was 20
that wasn't attacking enough because he
was too old at that point
let's look when he was 17 okay and this
is against my Chum Estevan oh wait a
minute I mean my pal Benko away I mean
it's fine Chum and he's from the country
you all know Hungary right okay in
Hungary actually had a good Olympic team
in 1980 amazing right okay they had
Lyles quarters we just showed and they
had Wrigley who was a candidate was old
time Wrigley and they had Chum and they
had and Reza Dorian who wrote the famous
book not too famous nobody he wrote the
book black is okay okay no he wasn't
black against Kasparov and it wasn't
okay okay so cuz tomorrow is white again
me again plays d4 opening this time we
have an Enzo Indian and Kasparov being
very aggressive played the move d5 okay
I move I would never play in fact one of
the world under 12 champion Kumar I
think he plays this with white but he
plays Knight f4 in this position which
is the other move okay so d5 very
aggressive this is very funny because in
this position black played the move
Bishop c5 and you would think in this
position black will never play Bishop c5
but since white played e5 blacks like
alright and it's very hard to move our
night off of e to because of discovered
checks play played g3 busier g2 that's
fair okay so why is losing some time to
get his Bishop active and this is a very
interesting position for me because if I
was white I would play passive and dad
and I would lose okay because I like to
play solid and when I think out on my
King Bishop like White's doing and I
have a point on d5 so I have a space
advantage I try to improve my position
slowly but I'm not a seventeen-year-old
Kasparov
okay and seventeen-year-old Kasparov
just checkmated you and when I look at
this position I don't think a checkmate
at all in fact the ship f5 is probably a
mistake because after Bishop f5 this
actually encourages what white does that
ends up winning the game and that was
sort of like in the last game when black
played Knight a5 and white played e5
playing for me because blacks Knight was
on 85 what move does Bishop f5 encourage
you what would mount Larsen say thumbs
up right look g4 you don't know that
yeah so you should be a good now by the
way today and for you two weeks ago Matt
Larsen play got a calm ski in Sweden in
the tournament and Matt was black and
was better winning the whole game than
the last 10 moves I forgot what happened
but calm ski 1 ok and I talked to him
about it he got in time trouble and on
everything so solid but he did I'll play
him with black so that's better than I
could do I play calm ski 2 but I forgot
I have to remove 3 what happened
ok bad memory okay so can smart off g4
Matt Larsen would be proud
problem is the Bishop on f5 doesn't have
a lot of squares and all of those pieces
that are defending blacks King because
Sparra attacks them with tempo he just
keeps attacking them and pushing his
pawns
okay so Bishop efore Knight g3 and this
extra reminds me of a game that I won
and that actually doesn't make that's
not too uncommon because I win so few
games that if remembering the games I
was like on one hand right I have a
funny hand I have extra digits right sit
right yeah that's right
okay and so I was playing out Chow way
before you were all born especially
Claudio okay like before Arjun was born
but way before claudia was born and in
my game with al chow we had white
squared bishops just like the players
here do and my opponent went to great
lengths to trade those white squared
bishops and then I played Knight f5 and
destroyed him that reminded me of this
game
black decided to trade the white scored
bishops and now that Knights going to
get to f5
or as I like to say knife f5 yeah cuz
part of us to do that although I did
learn the term knife f5 in 1984 this was
1980 hmm and the mysteries of life okay
so 9f8 as bent Larsen would say what's
that correct how come the history of
plural it has the right answer shocking
amazing night fa now black is safe and
white reason now why didn't resign
okay g5 Matt Larsen would be proud
h4 man Kasparov wasn't kidding because
smart I was like well these pieces are
all here and haven't moved I guess I'll
check me you okay that's why he's
Kasparov and we're sitting in a class
cold and Confused 95 h 5 f6 boo never
play f6 unfortunately I'm not sure what
black should do this night can't go
anywhere good the rook is being blocked
by the knight this Bishop is blocking
the other rook if it wants to get open
and whites just going to put a knight on
e4 Knight on f5 g6 h6 Rick h1 f4 I don't
know it looks like White's just a tax
black and black says oh well so he
played f6 trying to do something 94 and
he ruined
Kasparov spawn structure Butkus brought
activated his pieces and cos Prague
didn't care about pawn structure very
much he wanted all of his pieces near
your King and this is actually very nice
these Knights here
because they can't get kicked out the
knight on e5 what you all think is great
white can kick that out easily with f4
the knight on e4 can never get kicked
out the white knight on g3 is ready to
replace it in case of a trade and white
has Knight f5 and blacks King is getting
little open here Queen b6 saving his
Queen h6 9 f 7h g and it's looking tough
over there Knight d7 he doesn't want to
take the pawn
he thinks the pawn is actually helping
him it blocks White's pieces which could
possibly be true Czech Queen teh Queen
the b5 rook h1 and now something really
funny happened
Bishop b6 which is actually a good move
he wants to trade off the bishop he
wants to put pressure on this pawn so
this Queen can't be running away
anywhere Queen takes check on undie five
Queen f3 defending the pawn and after 95
how did white save his queen the trick
question
any student of mine should know the
answer
oh you ah not Knight f5 knife f5 yeah so
this is actually very funny okay this is
a humiliating part of the game for a
black blacks night is on f7 I can prove
it there it is
that's good proof and he moved it off of
f7 and he thought wow the Queen's going
to move and then I'll play Queen takes
d5 check and I'm the best and if Bishop
takes the knight he'll take with the
rook attacking the d5 pawn and getting
rid of the bishop on f6 so after here
threatening Knight h6 checked me he's
like hmm how do I stop Knight h6 maid
and he stopped it but I don't think
black got a lot accomplished there
Knight e5 back to f7 yeah so 95 is a
pretty silly move for a strong
Grandmaster who's playing on the Olympic
team plays after Knight f5 he had to go
back I have a theory are you guys
interested time trouble because the
guy's checkmating you the whole game g4
h 4g v h5 h6 and you're like him i hate
getting checkmated and so by defending
defending defending he probably had very
little time on his clock and he was like
okay 95 that attacks the Queen and white
can't attack me anymore and then he
played nine f5 and he's like oh okay and
now we play arjen's move it was the move
you just said yeah Rick aged seven I
hate when that happens
and as you can see like the Paul Morphy
that I love white has a few things
around the black king and like the last
game black has a lot of pieces not
defending the black King okay Rick aged
seven what do we say the truth hurts
okay in whites threatening Rick h8 Shak
and RG you're too young to see that
that's because it's terrible it's rated
X for extra strong attack right that is
good spelling right
for extra strong attack for everyone
this joke was funnier than mine
alright so route takes h7 and I keep
pushing the arrow but nothing happens
yeah okay and if she doesn't resign
probably King takes rook makes sense
Queen h5 is mate and 10 according to
what I read and rook h1 is made in five
and or six but they're playing moves
like give all their pieces away let them
queen with double mate terrible and so
for example this this would be good for
white there's like maiden to here hmm
there's some quick maid here if only I
knew what it was maybe King g6 wins and
you should have played on let's see if I
make a queen and then you take it is
this mate good answer yeah so this looks
good for white okay and obviously King
GA it's not very helpful talk about all
your pieces attacking okay now it looks
like Carlson's game because White has
two queens okay and then that would be
good for white so after rip takes h7
black resigned because it's all made and
his flag is falling and he's got nothing
so in that game black had a lot of
pieces on the Queen side not defending
his King so Kasparov started a big King
side attack just like in the game with
poor dish I didn't realize when I set up
the games that he's being the Hungarian
team so the Hungarians gonna be mad at
me losing to Kasparov who would have
thunk it and when Kasparov was very
young as in these games this is mainly
how he played and when he got older he
played better and more solid Carlson and
Karpov style but if this was slightly
inaccurate and it wasn't the exact right
way to play his opponents didn't know
why Mick Kyle tall style but probably
better than tall because he saw more
variations they'll tell us a lot of
variations but he wasn't as sick as tall
I mean maybe up here he was but not here
it's all had a lot of heart just not you
know yeah it all should have been should
have been alive this year because
everybody died this year not your year
our year your year doesn't matter
they're all in 2017 they're all confused
Wow how could be wars so for those of
you who were wondering at home the
answer is yes I'm still married although
by that time this video comes out and
who knows right I mean my wife was here
this morning and now she's not here
anymore
so and truth hurts yeah it's true yeah
yeah
is that right Arjun yeah that's right
she's home yeah Arjun is confused and
you give me a wedding present come on
aren't you like eight come on were your
responsibilities
[Music]
you
[Music]